but i tend to believe that
uh there's a much stronger
uh i i don't like to talk about
evolutionary advantages but it seems
like
it makes sense for love to be a more
powerful
emerging phenomena of our collective
intelligence versus
hate and evil and destruction because
from a survival from a niche perspective
it seems to be uh
like for in my own life and my thinking
about the intuition about
the way humans work together to solve
problems
it seems that love is a very useful tool
i definitely agree with you but i think
the caveat here is that
you know humans the research suggests
that humans are
are capable of great acts of kindness in
great acts of generosity
to people in their in group right
and so we're also tribal yeah i mean
that's the k
that's the kitschy way to say it we're
tribes we're tribal
yeah so that's the kitschy way to say it
what i would say is that
you know there are a lot of features
that you can use to describe yourself if
you don't have one identity
you don't have one self you have many
selves you have many identities
um sometimes you're a man sometimes
you're a scientist
sometimes you're a do you have a brother
or a sister a brother
so sometimes you're a brother you know
you you sometimes you're a friend
as you're human so you can keep zooming
out yes living organism on earth
yes exactly that's exactly that's
exactly right
and so um there are
there are some people who there is
research
which suggests that um there are some
people who will tell you
i think it's appropriate and better to
help
i should help my family more than i
should help my neighbors and i should
help my neighbors more than i should
help
the average stranger and i should help
um you know the average stranger in my
country more than i should help somebody
outside my country and
i should help humans more than i should
help you know other animals and
right so there's a clear hierarchy of
helping and there are other people
who um you know they
are their niche is much more inclusive
right
and that they're humans first
right or or creatures of the earth first
let's say
um and i i don't think we know how
flexible those attitudes are because i
don't think the research really tells us
that
but in any case there are you know and
there are beliefs
people also have beliefs about there's
this really interesting research
in um really an anthropology um
that looks at what are
cultures particularly afraid of like
what
the people in a particular culture are
organizing their social systems to
prevent certain types of
problems so what are the problems that
they're worried about and and
so there are some cultures that are much
more hierarchical
and some cultures that are you know much
more egalitarian
there are some cultures that you know in
the debate of like getting along versus
getting ahead there are some cultures
that
really prioritize the individual over
the group and there are other cultures
that really prioritize the group over
the individual
you know it's not like one of these is
right and one of these is wrong
it's that you know different
combinations of these features
are different solutions that humans have
come up with for
for living in groups which is a major
adaptive advantage of our species
um and it's not the case that one of
these is better and one of these is
worse
although as a person of course i have
opinions about that
and as a person right i i can say
i would very much prefer certain i have
certain beliefs and i really want
everyone in the world to live by those
beliefs
you know but as a scientist i know that
it's not really the case that for the
species
any one of these is better than any
other there are different solutions that
work
differently well in particular
you know ecological parts of the world
but for individual humans there are
definitely
some systems that are better in some
systems that are worse
you